I guarantee you you will learn things
about the King of Pop that you never
knew he didn't want to be the King of
Pop just wants to be Mike a normal
American dad the biggest surprise is
from the to our TV movie Michael went on
secret date with women and once even
tried to sneak into a bar the King of
Pop was broke he also had a strange
obsession with hot sauce and spray
butter he carried it everywhere he went
and another thing
Michael was terrified of performing I'm
not like these Vegas acts that's sit in
the corner and sing Kumbaya can't do
five nights a week it would kill me now
don't expect to hear any of MJ's music
his estate didn't give lifetime
permission to use it and you won't see
performances but Navi the impersonator
who portrays Michael in searching for
Neverland took the role because it's all
about showing him as a dad in a good
people in the world bad people I'll
always protect it was authentic it
wasn't the crap that you get that's just
sensationalized is about the man the
human being the father the person so how
does Michael's family feel about the
portrayal
I asked executive producer Suzanne de
Paz who discovered Michael and helped
create the Jackson 5 what did the family
say when they saw this and what was
their reaction I did show it to mrs.
Jackson and Jermaine it was a very
emotional experience would Michael be
happy with how things are going with
Paris and the kids Paris is a beautiful
young learning and very intelligent and
very sweet Michael would be proud listen
it's a Lifetime movie so it has its
sappy moment and Navi has a British
accent Michael did not but overall the
movie is really good and very very
entertaining it is worth the watch
[Music]
you